vamos a repasar la energía potencial
gravitacional que vimos hace muchos
vídeos para después hacer una analogía
con la energía potencial eléctrica
entonces vamos a empezar nuestro repaso
de energía potencial gravitacional
dibujando la superficie de la tierra o
sea no tiene que ser a fuerzas la tierra
puede ser cualquier otro objeto porque
cualquier objeto atrae objetos hacia él
a través de un cierto campo
gravitacional pero vamos a pensar en la
tierra porque es un poco más sencillo
bueno entonces lo que aprendimos hace
varios vídeos es que si colocamos una
masa m a una altura h a una cierta
altura h
entonces la energía potencial
gravitacional de ese objeto o de esta
masa estaba dada multiplicado la masa
con la constante de gravedad que es 9.81
metros sobre segundo al cuadrado en el
caso de la tierra multiplicado con la
altura también podríamos reescribir esto
como la fuerza gravitacional la voy a
poner así multiplicada por la altura
nada más combinamos estos dos términos
en este de acá y la idea detrás de la
energía potencial era que
el objeto por estar en esta posición
tenía una cierta energía que se podía
aprovechar cuando lo soltaba moss
entonces y ahora soltábamos este objeto
se iba empezar a acelerar e iba a
convertir toda esta energía potencial
bueno suponiendo que no se está
escapando nada de energía pero iba a
convertir esta energía potencial en
energía cinética entonces la energía
potencial tiene que ver con donde está
un objeto con su posición pero bueno
para adquirir esta energía potencial no
no podíamos haberlo obtenido así de
gratis
teníamos que haber llevado el objeto
desde la posición inicial que era el
suelo de la tierra hasta esta altura h
entonces podemos pensar a la energía
potencial gravitacional como el trabajo
necesario para mover el objeto hasta
este punto de acá y algo que es
importante es desde donde estamos
diciendo que estamos moviendo el objeto
desde desde una altura cero hasta hasta
una altura h vale hasta una altura h
bueno entonces cuál sería el trabajo
necesario para realizar eso para mover
el objeto desde cero hasta h pues para
empezar la fuerza que necesitamos que
necesitamos contrarrestar es fg es fg
sale entonces tenemos que contrarrestar
esta fuerza la bueno estaba hacia abajo
la puse hacia arriba porque hacia allá
tenemos que ir entonces debemos aplicar
una fuerza hacia arriba de la misma
magnitud que fg al principio puede que
necesitemos un poquito más para que el
objeto se empiece a mover pero en cuanto
se empiece a mover ya nada más
necesitamos seguir aplicando esto para
que se siga moviendo hacia arriba vale
bueno entonces esa es la fuerza que hay
que aplicar y cuál es la distancia que
necesitamos que necesitamos o bueno en
la cual necesitamos mover ese objeto
pues justo es h entonces recordando que
el trabajo que el trabajo está dado y
multiplicando la fuerza por la distancia
tenemos que en este caso
en este caso la fuerza del trabajo
perdón el trabajo requerido para mover
el objeto está dado por la fuerza que
estamos aplicando que es fg multiplicado
por la distancia que aquí sería h
entonces esto está muy padre porque
cuadra con lo de arriba y entonces al
parecer vamos bien pero ojo todo lo
hicimos tomando como punto de referencia
el suelo de la tierra pero bien
podríamos haber tomado como por un punto
de referencia 10 metros por debajo o
bien desde una plataforma de 5 metros de
hecho esto va a ser muy útil cuando
pensemos en otro tipo de energía
potencial o sea no nos interesa pensar
en la energía potencial como algo
relativo no como algo absoluto como en
este caso en este caso es absoluto
porque siempre el marco de referencia es
el cero vale pero nos interesa poder
tener pues un poco más de flexibilidad
por ejemplo o sea todavía en este
contexto podríamos pensar
en el trabajo requerido para levantar
algo que está a menos 5 metros o sea a 5
metros bajo suelo entonces ahora
podríamos pensar en una cierta energía
potencial
y energía potencial con respecto a este
punto de referencia y la podríamos
llamar pues no sé dejando con él algún
nombre energía potencial gravitacional
con respecto al punto menos 5 vale
entonces podríamos hacer algo de este
estilo a lo mejor no se utiliza mucho a
lo mejor si puede ser que alguien le
importe cuál es el trabajo necesario
para levantar objetos desde menos cinco
metros bueno entonces suficiente por
ahorita de la energía potencial
gravitacional vamos a la energía
potencial eléctrica y en realidad vamos
a ver que es algo muy similar sólo que
ahora la fuente de la energía potencial
es algo un poco distinto y tiene que ver
con campos eléctricos entonces déjame
dibujar por acá algo que cause un campo
eléctrico bueno antes de es una pequeña
aclaración o sea acá en la en el caso de
los campos gravitacionales pues no
tienen por qué ser constantes aquí como
estamos cerca de la tierra podemos
pensar que si es constante que no varía
mucho según varía la altura de modo
similar con los campos eléctricos pues
no necesariamente son constantes pero
vamos a utilizar un caso
o eléctrico constante para que las cosas
sean más sencillas y bueno si quieres
saber cómo se le hace para construirlo y
demostrar que en efecto lo es puedes ver
los vídeos anteriores pero la idea
básicamente es es tomarse una placa
cargada infinita aquí le estamos viendo
de lado y decir que tiene carga uniforme
y pensar que tiene carga uniforme vale
entonces en los vídeos pasados vimos que
eso lo que hacía era justo generar un
campo eléctrico uniforme bueno vamos a
pensar que esta placa infinita tiene
carga positiva y entonces al dibujar su
campo eléctrico se vería más o menos así
se verían flechas hacia arriba las
flechas son hacia arriba porque
acuérdate que que tenemos que ver hacia
dónde se iría una carga positiva y la
carga positiva se va a alejar de esta
placa cargada positivamente porque
tienen la misma carga entonces se verían
como puras flechitas de la misma
longitud vale de la misma longitud
ok
entonces vamos a algunas preguntas
interesantes o sea en el vídeo pasado
vimos cómo calcular pues la magnitud de
este campo eléctrico en términos de la
densidad de carga ahorita para
simplificar un poco las cosas vamos a
pensar que el campo eléctrico ya está
dado y es de 5 newtons por colom es un
campo bastante fuerte pero va a hacer
que las cuentas sean sencillas entonces
pregunta cuánto trabajo necesitamos
cuánto trabajo necesitamos para mover
una carga positiva de 2 con blums hasta
este punto de acá que está que está a 3
metros hacia abajo entonces está ésta de
acá es de 3 metros 3 metros entonces
cuánto trabajo necesitamos para hacer
ese movimiento está bueno necesitamos
ver cuánta fuerza hay que aplicar y qué
distancia la distancia ya la tenemos
entonces sería bueno tener la fuerza y
la fuerza que necesitamos para mover
esta carga pues justo debe de
contrarrestar la fuerza causada por el
campo eléctrico y cuál es esa fuerza
causada por el campo eléctrico pues es
una fuerza que va hacia arriba y que
podemos calcular
de la definición de de campo eléctrico
déjame poner la formulita por acá para
que empecemos a hacer un poco de cuentas
teníamos que el campo eléctrico estaba
dado por la fuerza y entre carga de este
forma desde de este modo la fuerza la
fuerza que ejerce el campo eléctrico
está dada por la carga multiplicada con
el campo eléctrico sale y aquí tenemos
la información para encontrar esa fuerza
la carga nos dicen que es de 2 kilos
el campo nos dicen que es de 5 newtons
por colom y entonces aquí sería igual a
10 a 10 minutos vale entonces justo para
poder mover esta carga necesitamos
contrarrestar esta fuerza tenemos que
hacer una fuerza hacia abajo de 10
newtons otra vez quizás al principio
debe ser un poco mayor pero bueno ya que
se empiece a mover basta aplicar 10
newtons hacia abajo va bueno ya tenemos
la fuerza que hay que aplicar pero lo
que nos interesa es encontrar el trabajo
entonces queremos ver el trabajo
necesario para movernos 3 metros y el
trabajo está dado y calculando fuerza
por distancia ya tenemos la fuerza que
es 10 newtons 10 newtons y la distancia
que es 3 metros 3 metros entonces el
trabajo sería igual a 30 newtons metros
y un newton metros es un newton metro es
un joule y entonces son 30 yoox muy bien
entonces justo esto es lo que vamos a
pensar como la energía potencial
eléctrica vale otra vez aquí tenemos
algo en términos de jules gilson
unidades pues
pero también de energía y entonces justo
pensamos en la energía potencial
eléctrica como la energía que tiene una
carga por estar en este punto bueno en
este caso por estar en este punto con
respecto a este punto eso es importante
siempre es con respecto a otro punto
vale entonces a esto de acá no se
podríamos podríamos ponerle un nombre
sofisticado como como la energía
potencial eléctrica que tiene que tiene
esta carga
no sé en el punto p 2 con respecto al
punto p 1 es una anotación bueno más o
menos complicada pero la idea es ese
siempre hay que decir en donde estamos y
con respecto a donde lo estamos
considerando bueno que más nos permite
hacer esto de la energía potencial
eléctrica pues no sé o sea por ejemplo
si conociéramos la masa déjame ponerlo
con un color brillante si supiéramos que
esta carga tiene una masa de un
kilogramo de un kilogramo entonces pues
podríamos hacer cosas como preguntarnos
lo siguiente o sea agarramos la carga la
movemos a este punto y ahora la soltamos
que sucede bueno pues el campo eléctrico
empezará a mover esa carga hacia arriba
y una buena pregunta sería saber sería
saber a qué velocidad va a estar esa
carga en este momento cuando llegue a
este punto de acá y bueno si suponemos
otra vez que no se escapa nada de
energía y por calor ni nada raro
entonces justo justo la la velocidad va
a estar dada por la fórmula de energía
cinética verdad porque toda la energía
potencial eléctrica
en este momento va a estar convertido en
energía potencial cinética y por lo
tanto podríamos hacer los siguientes
cálculos podríamos ponerle que 30 wheels
30 jules que son estos los de la energía
potencial eléctrica se convierten en
energía cinética y la energía cinética
está dada por un medio de la masa por la
velocidad al cuadrado vale sabemos que
la masa es 1 entonces esto es un medio
de la velocidad al cuadrado pasando el 2
multiplicando tenemos que la velocidad
al cuadrado es igual a 60 y por lo tanto
la velocidad sería igual a raíz a raíz
de 60 y raíz de 60 es más o menos como 7
puntos 7 y cachito va entonces podemos
hacer ese tipo de cosas entonces qué nos
dice que nos dice este pequeño problema
que acabamos de hacer que si movemos
esta carga a este punto y la soltamos
entonces a llegar otra vez al punto
inicial su velocidad va a ser como de
7.7 metros sobre segundo vale bueno
entonces esto está padre espero que esto
más o menos te dé una idea de qué
qué es la energía potencial eléctrica y
más o menos los dibuje aquí juntos para
que pudiéramos hacer la analogía y
veamos que no es algo muy distinto de la
energía potencial gravitacional de hecho
son bastante similares pero la principal
diferencia es que acá la fuente es un
campo eléctrico vale el campo eléctrico
es lo que causa la energía potencial
eléctrica bueno nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo